Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two. David,
P. You can call absolutely any time. This is so
funny. This is almost beyond parody. You guys,
if you've been listening for a while,
might be aware of all of the different
anti-vaccine people that regularly call in. One
such person is this guy, Eric from Massachusetts.
He's been calling in for two years. Every one of
his predictions is wrong. He cites non-existent
data. He says this about the vaccines,
that about the vaccines. His new thing is
that they're about to close. The vaccines, like a
dollar store, might close at 10. The vaccines are
about to close, he says. Take a listen to this.
Speaker 3: Hey, David, it's it's a mess. What are
you going to do when the vaccines are pulled?
Because that's what's going to happen next?
Speaker 1: No, they're just going to be closed
down. They're closing them down. I've been right
about everything I've told you. He has not been
right about anything he has said, by the way.
Speaker 3: But I'm right. And what will
you do? How will you back what we say?
You're going to have to pay it off by pharma.
Speaker 1: That's what we have received. No money
from Big Pharma. That is, if if anyone wants to
try to prove otherwise, which you would fail to
do. Democrats don't pay us. Big Pharma doesn't pay
us. George Soros doesn't pay. They're not paying
us. Why would they? They have no reason to.
Speaker 3: Well, I'm just wondering, do you
have a backup plan because this website thing
you got going on is about to crumble, right?
Speaker 1: That's what we called the circling the
drain meme for the last 15 years. Every day you
can find at least one YouTube comment saying, Wow,
this show is almost completely dead. And every
month we are bigger than we were the month before.
It's quite remarkable that they're still repeating
that one. So no, the vaccines are not going to be
closed. They are going to remain open on the bonus
show today. The website to get free COVID tests
delivered to your home is up and running. I've
ordered mine. We'll tell you how to order yours
when they're going to be going out. Puerto Rico
has gotten the green light to end its five year
bankruptcy. We will talk about what's going on,
and the Supreme Court is having quite an
anti-mask problem. Trump appointee Neil Gorsuch
just ignored a request from the Chief Justice John
Roberts for him to wear a mask out of respect for
Justice Sonia Sotomayor. What is going on
and why is Neil Gorsuch such a vile person?
We will talk about it on today's bonus show.
You can get instant access to the bonus show
by becoming a member at Join Packman dot com.
Don't miss it! Every day you get the bonus show
as a member, you get six hours earlier than
everybody else. A commercial free full episode
of the show. Don't wait till 9:00 p.m. Eastern
or for clips to publish. Become a member. You'll
get the show six hours earlier. Sign up at Join
Packman dot com and I will see you on the bonus.